Hey, gang, welcome to Smart List. We are a sweet new podcast starring myself, Sean Hayes, Jason Bateman, and Will Arnett, and we are complete idiots. So what we do is we bring on a guest and we ask them stuff, and they make us smarter. Hopefully. It's super cool. So please, come with us, enjoy the show. Now listen, I need to say this before we get too deep into this.
嘿，各位，欢迎收看《Smart List》。我们是一个由我自己肖恩·海斯（Sean Hayes）、杰森·贝特曼（Jason Bateman）和威尔·阿奈特（Will Arnett）主演的超棒新播客，我们全都是白痴。所以我们要做的就是请来一位嘉宾，问他们各种问题，然后他们让我们变得更聪明。希望如此。这太酷了。所以请和我们一起，享受节目吧。现在听着，在我们深入探讨之前，我必须先说这个。
I am about to have a COVID test because it's 2020 and I get them done like once a week or every 10 days we have to with the kids and mine just happens to coincide with us doing it. But at some point during the podcast, I'm going to have somebody come in and she's going to come in and give me that. That's not true. Yeah. Why?
我马上要做一个新冠检测，因为现在是2020年，我大概每周或每10天就要做一次，有孩子的话我们必须得做，而我的刚好和我们录节目撞上了。但播客进行到某个时候，会有人进来，她会进来帮我做那个。不对，不是这样的。对。为什么？
Why does it have to be during our time? And what is COVID? Oh, bless him. Why does she have to do it during our time? Because it was bad scheduling, bad scheduling, but a lot of things, conspiring kids tomorrow afternoon. I'm busy. Uh-oh.
为什么非要在我们录节目的时候做？还有，什么是新冠？哦，真可怜。为什么她非要在我们录节目的时候做？因为行程没安排好，行程没安排好，但很多事情赶到一块儿了，明下午有孩子们的事。我很忙。噢噢。
That's always boring. With you. Wait, what? Oh, you guys golfing? No, no, no. I don't know. We're going to charity meeting. Oh, I see.
那样总是很无聊。和你在一起。等等，什么？哦，你们去打高尔夫吗？不，不，不。我不知道。我们要去开一个慈善会议。哦，我明白了。
I guess I'm busy too. Yeah. Feeding kids. Busy. Making smiles. It's a charity meeting. I thought you were going to say after your COVID test, you were going to have like a reveal party of the results.
我想我也很忙吧。对。喂孩子。忙。制造微笑。这是一个慈善会议。我以为你会说做完新冠检测后，你要举办一个公布结果的派对呢。
Oh, yeah. You know, people get mad because I keep doing on the subway, I used to do gender reveals all the time. I'd wear a trench coat and I'd just go, hey, you know, and I'd just reveal my gender to people. That's so stupid. I know. It's so dumb.
哦，对。你知道的，人们会生气，因为我一直在地铁里做性别揭晓派对，我以前经常做。我会穿一件风衣，然后走过去说，嘿，你知道的，然后我就把我的性别揭晓给人们看。这太蠢了。我知道。太蠢了。
And people got mad for my gender reveals on the subway. Well, next time you, you have the results. I hear a female laughing. So your guest already, I can tell is a female or a fellow who is happy might sound careful like a female. Yes. Might sound like a female. Good for you.
人们对我在地铁里搞性别揭晓感到很生气。好吧，下次你，你拿到结果的时候。我听到一个女性的笑声。所以我可以听出来，你的嘉宾已经来了，是个女性，或者是一个听起来可能像女性的快乐的人，小心点，就像个女性。对。听起来像个女性。真不错。
Yes. Good for you. That's restraint. Look at, look how much you've grown. Oh, wait. So let me guess. I know it's a woman. It is.
对。真不错。这很有克制力。瞧瞧，瞧瞧你成长了多少。哦，等等。那我猜一下。我知道是个女人。是的。
It's a really, I don't know if you can tell by your laugh because mostly people are laughing at what she's doing. Okay. As a fellow, so she's a comedian. She's a comedian. Well, I mean, she's a lot of things stand up or actor. Let me, you ready for this? All of the above.
这是一个真正的，我不知道你们能不能从她的笑声中听出来，因为大部分人都在笑她正在做的事。好吧。作为一个同道中人，所以她是个喜剧演员。她是个喜剧演员。好吧，我是说，她是很多重身份，单口喜剧演员还是演员？让我，你准备好了吗？以上皆是。
God, she started as a stand up, then got into acting, then did sketch, then did SNL, then did her own show. One, two Emmys is a hilarious, just all around hilarious person. She's got a brand new podcast that is killing it. Taylor Stiller. Ladies and gents, Sean and Jason. Sarah Silverman is on the show today. Sarah Silverman!
天哪，她从单口喜剧起步，然后开始演戏，然后演小品，然后上周六夜现场（SNL），然后有了自己的节目。拿过两座艾美奖，是个搞笑的人，一个全方位搞笑的人。她有一个新播客，火得一塌糊涂。泰勒·斯蒂勒（Taylor Stiller）。女士们先生们，肖恩和杰森。萨拉·西尔弗曼（Sarah Silverman）今天来到我们的节目。萨拉·西尔弗曼！
Woo! Woo! Woo! Woo! Woo! Woo! Woo! Woo!
呜！呜！呜！呜！呜！呜！呜！呜！
Woo! Woo! Woo! Woo! Woo! Woo! Woo! Lis, I know!
呜！呜！呜！呜！呜！呜！呜！里斯，我知道！
You guys! Nice going. We're all such fans of yours. You're such a super comedy hilarious person. There she is. Will, what's your first question since you've had time to work on good questions, it's your guest. Let's have your best one right now.
你们这些家伙！干得好。我们都是你的超级粉丝。你是个超级搞笑的喜剧天才。她来了。威尔，既然你有时间准备好问题了，这是你的嘉宾，你有什么第一个问题？现在把你的杀手锏亮出来吧。
Okay. Sarah. Yeah. How's it goin'? Oh, that's good. No, I you listen... Gender Reveal on the subway is the funniest joke, by the way. It's so dumb, right?
好的。萨拉。对。最近怎么样？哦，这挺好。不，你听着……顺便说一句，地铁里的性别揭晓派对是最好笑的笑话。太蠢了，对吧？
It's so dumb! Great joke. Oh my God. I've been waiting to tell that for like four days, I've been waiting. When you said it, you know, when you hear something and you can't wait to tell a friend, you know? It wasn't quite that, but it was like, almost that.
太蠢了！绝妙的笑话。天哪。我憋了大概四天等着讲这个呢，我一直在等。当你听到它的时候，你知道的，当你听到一个笑话，你等不及要讲给朋友听，对吧？虽说没完全达到那种程度，但差不多就是那样。
Can I tell you something? So I'm gonna tell you this, Sarah. One of my favorite jokes that I have told many times over and over, or I've retold the scene, which is people's least favorite thing to hear when you're like, hey, do you remember the scene where? Was from your old program. So I'm gonna start in the middle.
我能告诉你件事吗？我要告诉你这个，萨拉。我最喜欢的笑话之一，我讲过很多遍，或者我重现过那个场景，而人们最讨厌听别人说“嘿，你还记得那个场景吗，当……”就是来自你的老节目。所以我从中间开始讲。
From the Sarah Silverman program, where you did on Comedy Central. Such a funny show. It's so good. And you did this bit. By the way, I don't know if you could do it today. It was the episode where you wanted some good news so you decided to get an AIDS test.
从喜剧中心（Comedy Central）播出的《萨拉·西尔弗曼节目》开始。太搞笑的节目了。太棒了。你演了这么个桥段。顺便说一句，我不知道你今天还能不能演。就是那一集，你想听到点好消息，于是决定去查一下艾滋病。
Right? Yeah. And first of all, there are like 80 jokes crammed in this tiny scene and you go, she goes, have you ever had unprotected sex? And you said, is there any other way? Then she said, in the 80s, and you said. No, yeah.
对吧？对。首先，在这个短短的场景里塞了大概80个笑话，然后她说，她问，你以前有过无保护性行为吗？你说，还有别的方式吗？然后她说，在80年代吗？然后你。不，对。
She goes, did you ever have unprotected sex in the 80s? And I go, oh my God, yes. And she goes, you did? You had unprotected sex in the 80s? And I go, oh, no. I thought you said in Haiti. So then she says, tell me how many times. And so you take a piece of paper and you start writing
她说，你在80年代有过无保护性行为吗？然后我说，天哪，有啊。然后她说，你有过？你在80年代有过无保护性行为？然后我说，哦，没有。我以为你说的是在海地。然后她说，告诉我次数。于是你拿出一张纸开始写，
and you hand it to her and she goes, what's that? And you go, that's the number. And she goes, there are two numbers. And you said, yeah, for the front and back. And she goes, they're the same number. And you said, yeah, I'm kind of OCD like that. It was like a domino effect of jokes. It just like started and it was just nonstop.
然后你递给她，她问，那是什么？你说，那是次数。她说，有两个数字。你说是的，前面和后面。然后她说，这两个数字是一样的。你说是的，我在这方面有点强迫症。这就好比是笑话的骨牌效应。一个接一个，根本停不下来。
Fuck me, man. I have told that, that's such a funny bit. And it's such a, everything about that scene was, again, I don't know, I think people might be offended today. I don't know. There are a lot of problematic things looking back, but you know, such is comedy, it's not evergreen. Right.
操，天哪。我讲过那个，那个桥段太搞笑了。而且那个场景的方方面面，再说一次，我不知道，我觉得现在的人可能会被冒犯。我不知道。回过头来看，有很多存在问题的地方，但你知道的，喜剧就是这样，它不是常青树。对。
So that's my thing is like, you've always been such a, I don't know, such a fucking stupid word, edgy, but you know, cutting it. Good for you, Sean. Thank you, thank you. You're getting prayer hands. Go ahead. Prayer hands, prayer hands. That, what is it?
所以我的意思是，你一直是个，我不知道，这个词真他妈蠢，前卫，但你知道的，尖锐。干得好，肖恩。谢谢，谢谢。你这是在做祈祷手势。继续。祈祷手势，祈祷手势。那个，是什么？
It's always about the messenger of the joke. It's never really about the, so you can say like on the Sarah Silverman program, you could do a joke about AIDS like that and people embrace it and laugh because it's you saying it. So what do you think is the difference between you saying it and somebody else saying it
关键在于笑话的传达者是谁。从来都不是关于，所以你可以像在《萨拉·西尔弗曼节目》里那样，开一个关于艾滋病的玩笑，人们会接受并大笑，因为是你说的。所以你认为你说这话和别人说这话有什么区别？
and not getting away with it? It seems like you get away with a lot of stuff because you're so fucking funny, but it's, some of it's pretty dark. I think it's the intention behind it. Like this is a math term, but it's kind of like the absolute power of the joke. Like especially back then I always said
而且还没惹上麻烦？看起来你逃过了很多麻烦，因为你他妈太搞笑了，但其中有些内容挺黑暗的。我觉得是背后的意图。就像这是一个数学术语，但有点像笑话的绝对效力。尤其是早期，我总是说
the opposite of what I thought, you know, and that was the joke kind of. And then hopefully the truth transcends that I don't really feel this way, not to break it down in the least funny possible way, but it is also interesting too because like that comedy I did, you're right, it was like,
相反的话，你知道的，这就是那个笑话的本质。希望真理能超越这一点，我并不是真的这么想，虽然这听起来一点也不好笑，但这也很有趣，因为就像我演的那种喜剧，你说得对，就像是，
oh, it's okay because you know I don't mean it, but then it also is kind of like we're liberal so we can say anything. So we could say, you know, the words that are unsayable or whatever like, you know I don't mean it, so I could say it. Like there is kind of like a liberal like douchiness about it I think and in retrospect,
哦，没关系，因为你知道我不是认真的，但同时这也带有一种“我们是自由派，所以我们可以畅所欲言”的感觉。所以我们可以说，你知道的，那些不能说出口的话之类的，你知道我不是认真的，所以我就可以说。这其中有一种自由派式的自以为是，我觉得，回想起来，
I mean, I don't know, it's a weird balance. I think you're right, I was thinking about that the other day which is like what's been gone is things have gotten so serious because everybody who's not liberal is so serious and so dark and so real about their negativity or hate or racism or whatever it is that it's taken all of that away.
我是说，我不知道，这是一种奇怪的平衡。我觉得你说得对，我前几天还在想这个，那就是有些东西已经消失了，因为事情变得太严肃了，因为所有不属于自由派的人都太严肃了，对他们的负面情绪、仇恨、种族主义或任何事情都太认真、太阴暗、太真实了，以至于把所有这些都剥夺了。
You're like, I don't even want to joke about anything, a lot of things that are rough or maybe pushing boundaries because you feel like I don't want it to be taken the wrong way because there are so many people who mean it. Right. There's not enough distance, you know, it's like so close, like people go, oh, it's so funny.
你会觉得，我甚至不想拿任何事情开玩笑了，很多比较粗俗或者可能在试探底线的事情，因为你觉得我不想被误解，因为有太多人是认真的。没错。没有足够的距离感，你知道的，就好像离得太近了，人们会说，哦，太搞笑了。
I saw like a comment in Spanish of something that I wrote and I go, ooh, you know, I have a fan that's Spanish, you know, that I press translate and it was just a, why don't you stick to comedy and leave politics out of it, I was like, oh. So wait, I'm sure you've had your share of criticism like we all have like positive negative but is there someone in your life that mattered to you
我看到有人用西班牙语评论我写的一段话，我说，哦，你知道的，我有个西班牙粉丝，你知道的，我按了翻译，结果内容就是，为什么你不好好搞喜剧，别扯上政治，我当时就想，哦。所以等等，我敢肯定你也有过不少批评，就像我们所有人一样，有积极的也有消极的，但在你生命中，有没有哪个对你重要的人，
who said that you may have taken certain materials too far or something like that? Which of your friends have you offended, Sarah? And lost forever. I've actually kind of made friends that started out as like them calling me out. Right. Interesting. You know.
说过你可能把某些题材搞得太过火了之类的话？萨拉，你得罪过哪些朋友？并且永远失去了他们。实际上，有些朋友最开始是通过公开指责我才认识并成为朋友的。没错。真有意思。你知道的。
I would guess and please correct me, but I would guess that one of the things that appeals to you about comedy, about thinking of funny stuff and crafting it into something, you know, in order to deliver to an audience is about identifying that which makes some of us uncomfortable as opposed to some people look, it seems to me, look at other things that makes them excited about comedy.
我猜——请纠正我，但我猜吸引你从事喜剧的原因之一，也就是构思搞笑的事物并将其打造成某种东西（你知道的），为了呈献给观众，就是在于找出那些让我们当中某些人感到不自在的东西，与此相对的是，有些人，在我看来，他们关注喜剧的其他兴奋点。
With you, it seems like there, you have an affinity for as do I, trying to identify the thing that all kind of makes us a little bit uneasy because it only exists in our smallest place and you want to kind of bring that out and amplify that and share a common sort of reference point. So are you finding that you're frustrated
对你来说，似乎你有一种倾向——我也是——试图找出那种让我们所有人都感到有点不安的事物，因为它只存在于我们内心最角落的地方，而你想要把它挖掘出来、放大，并分享一个共同的参照点。所以你是否发现自己感到沮丧，
that outside sources seem to be narrowing those borders and those walls and now you have to kind of think twice and three times about that? Or do you not listen to that? I think like what you said, edgy or, you know, I know it's corny or whatever, but it's like you can't have it both ways. Like if you do something that is risky,
因为外界似乎在缩小这些边界和高墙，现在你不得不对这些事情三思而后行？还是说你根本不理会这些？我觉得就像你说的，前卫或者，你知道的，我知道这很老套什么的，但这就好比鱼和熊掌不可兼得。如果你做了一件冒险的事，
you have to be risking something. Like there are consequences. Like you can't get mad that there are consequences. And I don't mind, I like like when young people, you know, like students or whatever, like they teach me new language. I'm into that. Cause I feel like they're always on the right side of history
你就必须承担风险。就像会有后果一样。你不能因为有后果而生气。我不介意，我喜欢年轻人，你知道的，比如学生之类的人，他们教我新的语言。我很喜欢这样。因为我觉得他们总是站在历史正确的一边，
and I want to like learn new words and pronouns, even though I fuck up all the time. Fire, by the way, is a new one for something that's good. Okay. That's not that new. Fire. No, it's brand new. It started yesterday.
我想学习新词汇和代词，尽管我总是搞砸。顺便说一句，“Fire”是用来形容好东西的新词。好的。那也不是特别新。“Fire”。不，这是全新的。昨天才刚开始。
That's not new, granddad. I had a guy tell me, I had a guy tell me on Twitter, I was, made me think about, you know, there's an ad that came out for Biden with Sam Elliott doing the voice up for it. I don't know if you heard it. And so I just, I retweeted it.
这可不新，老头子。有人在推特上对我说，有人在推特上对我说——这让我想起，你知道的，拜登出了一个广告，是山姆·艾略特（Sam Elliott）为它配音的。我不知道你有没有听过。于是我转发了。
I said the, the VO master, right? Cause he's just like the voiceover idol of mine. Like he's so good. All I said was VO master and this guy responded, stick to comedy. And I thought, wait a second. Do you do voiceovers, Will? Who's asking?
我说，配音大师，对吧？因为他简直就是我心中的配音偶像。他太棒了。我只说了一句“配音大师”，然后这家伙回复说：“专心搞喜剧吧。”我在想，等一下。威尔，你做配音吗？谁在问？
You have to be one thing. You have to be the one thing I know you as. Right, yeah. Exactly. You are a monolith. And it was within my, and I'm like, I can't even comment on voiceover. Like, wait a second.
你只能做一件事。你必须是我认识的那唯一一件事。对，没错。完全正确。你是个刻板单一的人。这就在我的范围内，而我却想，我甚至连配音都不能评论。等一下。
Also, like whoever's saying that, what do they do for a job? Are they a critic? I hope that they are only a critic. I hope so too. Right. So speaking of sticking to what you do, you started, you started doing standup when you were young.
还有，不管是谁说的，他们是做什么工作的？他们是评论家吗？我希望他们只是个评论家。我也希望如此。好吧，说到坚守本行，你很年轻就开始了，你很早就开始做单口喜剧了，
Right? Like, like a. 17. 17. That always blows my mind when standups start that. I know me too. That's so scary. You have more courage at 17, don't you? I did.
对吧？就像个。17岁。17岁。单口喜剧演员这么早开始，总是让我感到震惊。我知道，我也是。太吓人了。你在17岁时更有勇气，不是吗？我确实有。
I was a bed wetter until I was almost 16. So by the time that I did standup, but nothing is humiliating. Nothing competes with that kind of humiliating. But how did you know how to write at that young of age? Like, how did you know how to craft and construct a joke? I mean, it wasn't good. You know, I just did it.
我直到快16岁时还尿床。所以等我去做单口喜剧时，已经没有什么好羞耻的了。没有什么能比那种羞耻感更甚了。但你那么年轻是怎么知道怎么写段子的？比如，你怎么知道如何构思和构建一个笑话？我是说，其实写得并不好。你知道的，我就是去做了。
I wasn't a good comedian. I like did like jokes about, you know, I went to a high school actually that was really, they'd have an assembly on Mondays and Fridays and they'd let me do like a couple minutes. No way. And I had a math teacher that would let me like,
我当时不是个优秀的喜剧演员。我只是写一些关于，你知道的，我上过一所高中，实际上那里的规矩是周一和周五开全校大会，他们让我上去讲个两分钟。不会吧。我有一个数学老师，他允许我
tell a joke at the beginning of every class as long as I shut up the rest of it. Oh wow. And it was nice. It was like, it was really encouraging. I studied piano. I know this is where everybody passes out. I studied piano and classical music when I was much younger
在每节课开始时讲个笑话，只要我在剩下的时间里闭嘴就行。哦，天哪。这挺好的。这真的很令人鼓舞。我学过钢琴。我知道这是所有人都会昏过去的地方。我小的时候学过钢琴和古典音乐，
and I remember in high school, my dentist told me that he and his wife were throwing a Christmas party and I would, would I come over and play background music at the party on the piano? And I'm like, yeah, totally. Wow.
我记得在高中时，我的牙医告诉我，他和妻子要办一个圣诞派对，我愿不愿意过去在派对上弹钢琴做背景音乐？我说，好啊，完全可以。哇。
And serve drinks. Yeah, and serve drinks. And wear this outfit. And can you park cars or? Right. Do you mind wearing a mask? The point is when I was done, he handed me $100. And I was blown away that I got paid for a talent
还要端茶倒水。对，还要端茶倒水。还要穿这套衣服。你还能泊车吗？对。你介意戴个口罩吗？重点是，当我弹完后，他塞给我100美元。我当时震惊极了，因为我居然能靠才华赚钱，
that I got something in exchange for the years I put into honing this craft. Do you remember the first time you got paid as a standup and like what that was like? Did you report it? And do you remember how old you were? When I was 19, I did a road gig at a club called Joker's Wild.
我为磨炼这门手艺付出了多年的努力，并且因此得到了回报。你还记得你第一次作为单口喜剧演员拿到报酬是什么时候吗？那是怎样的体验？你报税了吗？你还记得你多大吗？我19岁时，在一家名为“Joker's Wild”的俱乐部接了一场路演。
And what's the town that has Yale in it? But it's like the sides Yale, it's gross. Okay, sorry. I mean, wonderful. So it was like this low rung mob run place called Joker's Wild. I was the emcee. For six shows, I got all together $100.
有耶鲁大学所在的那个镇叫什么来着？但它在耶鲁旁边，很糟糕。好吧，抱歉。我是说，非常美妙。所以那是一个由黑帮运营的低端场所，叫“Joker's Wild”。我是主持人。演了六场，我总共拿到了100美元。
Less than Sean got for them. And they harassed me the whole time and kept asking me to do cocaine. And I had to find my own place to stay. And I stayed with these elderly cousins of friends of my moms that were both deaf. It was like a rough week. It was really odd.
比肖恩拿的还少。而且他们全程骚扰我，一直让我吸可卡因。我还得自己找住处。我住在我妈妈朋友的年迈表亲家里，他们两个都是聋子。那真是一个艰难的一周。真的很奇葩。
And you're all jitsed out too. Oh, so you're all jitsed out. No, I did not. I did not do cocaine. But yeah, in the headliner that week, I won't say is, you probably wouldn't know him, but he ended up kind of losing everything. He was like, at that point he was married.
而且你当时也high大了。哦，所以你high大了。不，我没有。我没有吸可卡因。但是，对，那周的头牌，我不会说是谁，你们可能也不认识他，但他最后好像失去了一切。他当时，他那时已经结婚了。
He just had a kid and he was such a nice guy. Mostly impressions. But then I heard a friend of mine was in NA with him. And he did a brilliant thing. You know, comics are so dark. They're very close to criminals, you know? But he would go to open houses and use the bathroom and steal all their drugs,
他刚刚有了一个孩子，他人那么好。主要靠模仿。但后来我听说我有个朋友和他一起在戒毒互助会（NA）。他做了一件绝妙的事。你知道，喜剧演员都挺阴暗的。他们离罪犯很近，你知道吗？但他会去参观开放式房屋，然后借用他们的卫生间，偷走他们所有的毒品，
you know, all their medications and stuff. Wow. My next question is, what's the perfect balance for you from comedies? Like, what do you like to do that balances you out on any particular day or week or month, hobbies or? I'm so boring. I love television.
你知道的，所有他们的药物之类的。哇。我的下一个问题是，对你来说，喜剧的完美平衡是什么？比如，在任何特定的一天、一周或一个月里，你喜欢做什么来让你保持平衡，有什么爱好之类的？我很无聊。我喜欢看电视。
Television, watching television. Ozark, oh my gosh. There we go, I got it. Oh my God. Great interview, guys. She hasn't said it's good yet, let her finish. Ozark, what, Ozark, what? It's such a solid B of a show. No, it's a God.
电视，看电视。奥沙克（Ozark），哦天哪。好了，我懂了。天哪。精彩的采访，伙计们。她还没说好呢，让她说完。奥沙克，什么，奥沙克怎么了？这是一部非常扎实的B级剧。不，天哪。
I just, I thought, so anyway, you don't need to, but I just am a big fan of all of you. Like what, mostly? Like individually, I could go off, but I just want to say you're, and you're, you know, all of you are brilliant actors, brilliant performers, but you're directing is like, it's really beautiful. And I thought season three was phenomenal.
我只是，我当时想，所以不管怎样，你们不需要，但我只是你们所有人的超级粉丝。比如什么，主要是？单拎出来我能滔滔不绝，但我只想说你，还有你，你知道的，你们所有人都是杰出的演员，杰出的表演者，但你的导演功底，真的很棒。我觉得第三季简直绝了。
Come on. And that's all you get. That's a lot. Thank you, I will take it. That'll get me to sleep tonight. And Will, you're, you're, the Reese's commercials. Oh, Reese's, yeah, the Reese's. Sorry, not sorry.
拜托。这就完了？这就够了。谢谢，我会接受的。今晚我能睡个好觉了。还有威尔，你，你，那个里特斯（Reese's）巧克力豆的广告。哦，里特斯，对，那个里特斯。抱歉，绝不抱歉。
Unbelievable, sorry. So you like watching drama stuff, or do you watch it all? Yes, dramas. What about like reality shows? Like what about Bachelor? Do you have like a guilty pleasure like that? I am watching the Bachelor with my lover.
难以置信，抱歉。所以你喜欢看剧情片，还是什么都看？是的，剧情片。那真人秀呢？比如《单身汉》（Bachelor）？你有什么类似这种的罪恶快感吗？我和我爱人一起在看《单身汉》。
Yeah. Yeah, and we have a lot of fun. My wife loves that. It's just fun, it's so dumb. I know, yeah. But it's so fun, it's just big laughs all throughout. But besides that, I like dramas, yeah. Do you want to act in one of those,
对。对，我们看得很开心。我妻子很喜欢这个。这很有趣，太蠢了。我知道，对。但太有趣了，全程都是大笑。除此以外，我喜欢剧情片，是的。你想在其中一部里演个角色，
or do you just want to watch them? Yeah, I would like to act in one of those, but I love watching them. I think it's like watching comedy can be, when it happens, I'm like, I enjoy it, but it's never my go-to because it's just kind of a little more stressful than, you know, watching a thriller.
还是只想看它们？是的，我想在其中一部里演个角色，但我更喜欢看它们。我觉得看喜剧，当它好笑的时候，我会想，我很享受，但它从来都不是我的首选，因为它比看惊悚片要稍微多一点压力。
I would say it's like, you know, doctors don't run home and watch Crazy Anatomy. Right, yeah. It's like that. You've never said that, Sean. That's a fucking lie. You've never said that. Sean always says that.
我想这就像，你知道的，医生不会跑回家去看《实习医生格蕾》（Grey's Anatomy）。没错，对。就是那种感觉。你从没说过这话，肖恩。这他妈是个谎话。你从没说过。肖恩总是这么说。
He does. Yeah, but a thriller, yeah, I'd love to be in a, like a, or like a tactical, is that right, like a born, a born movie? Or like a, you know what I started recording because they've been playing them, is Old Columbo's from the 70s. And they're so good.
他确实说过。对，但惊悚片，是的，我很想参演一部，比如谍影重重（Bourne）那种电影？或者像，你知道我开始录制什么了吗，因为他们一直在重播，那是70年代的老《神探科伦坡》（Columbo）。真的太棒了。
Oh, Columbo's. They're like watching a 70s movie, like they're on film. That's Peter Falk, right? Peter Falk, and the episode we watched was Ruth Gordon in a rare role as a rich lady. Oh, lover. Yes.
哦，科伦坡。就像在看一部70年代的电影，它们是用胶片拍的。那是彼得·福克（Peter Falk），对吧？彼得·福克，我们看的那集里露丝·戈登（Ruth Gordon）罕见地饰演了一个有钱贵妇。哦，太棒了。是的。
She's my favorite. Harold and Maude, yes. Of course. And my favorite movie is Where's Papa? Every Which Way But Lose. Huh? Every Which Way But Lose. With Clint Eastwood, where she goes.
她是我最喜欢的。《哈罗德和莫德》（Harold and Maude），是的。当然。我最喜欢的电影是《爸爸在哪里？》（Where's Papa?）《任性》（Every Which Way But Lose）。哈？《任性》。由克林特·伊斯特伍德主演，里面她说道。
And Any Which Way You Can. Sure. And Any Which Way You Can, with one of my favorite lines in any movie, when the orangutan is on the thing, and she goes, what are you doing? Eating all the yori-yobes, scrapping all over the place.
还有《金拳大对决》（Any Which Way You Can）。当然。还有《金拳大对决》，里面有我最喜欢的电影台词之一，当红毛猩猩在那个东西上时，她说，你在干什么？吃光所有的洋芋饼，把这里砸个稀巴烂。
That's one of my favorite lines. She always leads with her thumb. Yeah. Oh. Let me ask you this. So, Sarah, can I wanna go back to when you started doing, do you remember- Hi, you guys. Hi, Sarah Silverman.
那是我最喜欢的台词之一。她说话总是竖起大拇指。对。哦。让我问你这个。所以，萨拉，我想回到你开始做，你还记得——嗨，你们好。嗨，萨拉·西尔弗曼。
I'm just happy to see your faces. Sorry, go on. No, no, no. We'll let it all, we'll make it clean. No, we don't have to. I'm only asking questions because Sean gets really mad if we don't stick to asking questions.
我只是很高兴看到你们的脸。抱歉，你们继续。不，不，不。我们会把这些都保留，我们会剪干净的。不，我们不用。我问问题只是因为如果我们不坚持问问题，肖恩会非常生气。
But- He doesn't like conversation. He doesn't like conversation. And then he feels that the people in the middle of the country in Wisconsin are mad if we're not getting information out of our guests. So, our guest today is Sarah Silverman, just to remind everybody, Sean, happy now. And Sarah, I just wanted,
但是——他不喜欢聊天。他不喜欢聊天。然后他觉得威斯康星州中部的人会生我们的气，如果我们没有从嘉宾那里榨出信息的话。所以，我们今天的嘉宾是萨拉·西尔弗曼，提醒大家一下，肖恩，现在高兴了吧。萨拉，我只是想，
I was thinking about you being 17, being on stage and you're trying to write jokes and you were joking that like they weren't any good. But can you remember like your first joke that you thought was funny? Yeah. That maybe still is. Yeah.
我在想你17岁的时候，站在舞台上，你试图写笑话，你刚才开玩笑说那些笑话其实并不好。但你还记得你觉得好笑的第一个笑话吗？对。可能现在依然觉得好笑的。对。
Yeah. My friend, Eric Noyes, said, does my breath smell like tacos? And I said, I don't know, do you put shit in your tacos? That was in high school. But I found an old notebook. Like I save all my notebooks.
对。我的朋友埃里克·诺伊斯（Eric Noyes）说：“我的口气闻起来像塔可饼吗？”我说：“我不知道，你在塔可饼里拉屎了吗？”那是高中时候的事。但我找到了一本旧笔记本。我保留了我所有的笔记本。
I found a notebook from when I was like 19 and there were jokes in there that were so bad. Like, and reading it written, you know, goes, and a lot of my jokes early on were like, I don't know. I'm just, so it was like, I don't know why my goldfish died.
我找到了一本我大约19岁时的笔记本，里面的笑话太烂了。而且读着写下来的东西，你知道的，上面写着，我早期的很多笑话就像是，我不知道。我只是，所以就像是，我不知道我的金鱼为什么死了。
I put it in a tank, dot, dot, dot, beat, top. A tank top. Yeah, sure. Do you have a set time each day that you dedicate to, all right, I'm going to stare at the wall. I'm going to think of stuff I can write down for possible performance or script or whatever it is.
我把它放进鱼缸（tank）里，点，点，点，拍（beat），背心（top）。背心（tank top）。对，当然。你每天有没有固定的一段时间专门用来，好吧，我要盯着墙发呆。我要想想可以写下来用于表演、剧本或任何东西的东西？
Or do you just kind of just let stuff happen to you and you always have a little thing in your pocket and you could be at a red light, you can think of something and you write it down. Mostly the latter. When I'm my best self, I do, sometimes I'm just sitting in a chair and it really is like,
还是说你只是让事情自然发生，你口袋里总有个小本本，你可能在等红灯时想到了什么就把它写下来？基本上是后者。当我处于最佳状态时，我确实会这样做，有时我只是坐在椅子上，真的就像是，
I remember someone calling me and I was just sitting in a chair in my room and they're like, what are you doing? And I'm like, working. And I know I was being defensive, but I do feel like a lot of it is just sitting, you know, stillness if you can. I thought about the title of your memoir
我记得有人打电话给我，我当时正坐在房间的椅子上，他们问：“你在干什么？”我说：“在工作。”我知道我当时在为自己辩解，但我确实觉得很多时候就是在静坐，如果可以的话，保持静止。我想过你的自传的名字，
if you haven't got one already and I want you to consider Goldfish in a Tank Top. That does sound like a comedian's. Doesn't it sound like a comedian? That would be great. You have to put the ellipses in between tank and top. Goldfish in a tank dot, dot, dot. Turn page, flip over, top.
如果你还没起好的话，我想让你考虑一下《鱼缸里的背心》（Goldfish in a Tank Top）。这听听确实很像喜剧演员写的。不觉得很像喜剧演员吗？那太棒了。你必须在“tank”和“top”之间加上省略号。金鱼在缸（tank）里，点，点，点。翻页，翻过去，背心（top）。
And then in parentheses, get it. Right. Upside down question. L-O-L-J-K-J-K-J-K. K-J-K-J-K as far as the eye can see. Jared, I have to ask the cliche question to another funny person. Like, what do you like?
然后括号里写着，懂了吗。对。倒过来的问号。L-O-L-J-K-J-K-J-K。满眼望去全都是J-K。杰瑞德，我得问另一个搞笑之人的俗套问题。比如，你喜欢什么？
Favorite food? What the fuck happened to you as a kid that made you funny? Well, I mean, I think I was extremely her suit. You know, I was growing up in New Hampshire. Really, I didn't know Jews. I didn't, you know, I didn't go to, like, a lot of people go, oh, all the bar mitzvah season and all that stuff. I didn't have any of that.
最喜欢的食物？你小时候到底发生了什么才让你变得这么搞笑？好吧，我是说，我觉得我以前体毛极其旺盛。你知道的，我在新罕布什尔州长大。真的，我不认识犹太人。我没有，你知道的，我没有去过，就像很多人说的，哦，赶上所有的犹太成人礼（Bar Mitzvah）季节之类的事。我根本没有经历过这些。
Like, my parents are atheists. They call themselves agnostic to be more polite. Or Jewish to be even more polite. But like, there weren't Jews. So we, like my sister says, we thought being Jewish just meant being a Democrat, because that's how we were different in New Hampshire, you know?
比如，我的父母是无神论者。他们为了显得更有礼貌而自称是不可知论者。或者为了显得更有礼貌而自称是犹太人。但像那时并没有犹太人。所以我们，就像我姐姐说的，我们以为当犹太人只意味着当民主党员，因为那是我们在新罕布什尔州与众不同的地方，你知道的？
But I think because of that, I was like, I was really hairy too. And yeah, like my dad goes, you know, you want your dad to just think you're so beautiful. And he does, but he was like, in high school, he goes, if you want to spend a summer getting electrolysis, I'll pay for it. And I was like, why would I do that?
但我觉得正因为如此，我当时，我也真的很毛茸茸的。然后，对，我爸爸说，你知道的，你总是希望你爸爸觉得你美极了。他确实这么觉得，但他在我上高中时说，如果你想花一个夏天去做电解脱毛，我出钱。我当时就想，我为什么要那样做？
Jesus. Oh, never mind. He really just meant it to be nice, but then I think he was horrified, because I was like, why would I do that? We should be acknowledging this, by the way. I'm sorry. Well, you don't need to do the brain scratcher anymore.
天哪。哦，没关系。他其实只是想说好听的，但后来我觉得他吓坏了，因为我说：“我为什么要那样做？”顺便说一句，我们应该承认这一点。抱歉。好吧，你不需要再挠头了。
Why would I do that? Yeah, I want to be thorough. Did they just stick a thing up your nose for this? Yes. The shallow ones are thorough, and so is the saliva one now. I mean. If it doesn't, dude, if it doesn't hurt, if there's no pain, then it's not fucking valuable. Have you not learned that lesson in life? That's what my dad said right before you came in.
我为什么要那样做？对，我想弄清楚。他们刚才是不是为了这个把什么东西捅进你鼻子了？是的。浅表检测就很彻底，现在的唾液检测也是。我是说。如果没有，老兄，如果它不疼，如果没有任何痛苦，那它就他妈的一点价值也没有。你还没从生活中吸取这个教训吗？我爸在你进来之前刚说过这话。
My dad was right when he said, God, you're stupid. What the fuck is wrong with you? You'll be nothing. You're not listening to your crime. Write in between the times that he never told me he loved me in my whole life. No, it's interesting about that. So you know how that makes people go into show business?
我爸说得对，他说：“天哪，你太蠢了。你他妈到底怎么了？你什么都不是。你根本不听你的罪行。”就在他这辈子从未对我说过他爱我的那些时光之间。不，关于这个很有趣。所以你知道这为什么会让人进入演艺圈吗？
Like, my mom only, she just read People Magazine, and she didn't look up from it. She didn't come to my games. She didn't, you know, so it's like, I think a part of me wanted to get into People Magazine. You know what I mean? Right, right. And I think all of us have, I'm sure that.
比如，我妈妈只会，她只看《人物》（People）杂志，而且头都不抬一下。她不来看我的比赛。她不，你知道的，所以我觉得，我的一部分原因大概是想上《人物》杂志。你知道我的意思吗？对，对。而且我想我们所有人都有，我敢肯定。
Yes. Sarah, you mentioned that your parents didn't go to your game. My dad did. What game? What sport did you play? Every sport. I was, you know, listen, I'm not bragging. No, tell us. I was a fast pitch pitcher for the state of New Hampshire.
是的。萨拉，你提到你的父母没有去看你的比赛。我爸去了。什么比赛？你打什么运动？所有的运动。我，你知道的，听着，我不是在吹牛。不，告诉我们。我是新罕布什尔州的垒球投手。
No, wow. Come on. Of softball. Sure, yeah, yeah. Not to minimize it. And, you know, and I played soccer and I played basketball. I still play basketball, although I haven't since COVID. And now I'm like, do I still play basketball?
真的，哇。拜托。垒球。当然，对，对。不是在贬低它。而且，你知道的，我还踢足球，打篮球。我现在还在打篮球，虽然新冠之后就没打了。现在我在想，我还打篮球吗？
Because like my bones are so rickety now. But when you do play, it's not, you're not going down to like the local park and doing a pickup game. You have an organized game or a bunch of your friends get together? I have gone to pickup games and I do play pickup games, but the two games I've been playing out here
因为我的骨头现在太脆了。但当你真的去打的时候，不是，你不是去当地公园打野球。你是有组织的一场比赛，还是一群朋友聚在一起？我去过野球局，我也打野球，但我在这里打的这两场比赛，
for the past couple of years, I don't know anyone there outside of that game. Like I don't. What's the difference between a pickup game and a game? It's all strangers. Yeah, you just show up and you say, hey, I want to play. All right. Well, maybe I'll sign up for one.
过去几年里，除了那场比赛之外，我不认识那里的任何人。我不知道。野球和正规比赛有什么区别？全都是陌生人。对，你只要出现然后说，嘿，我想打。好吧。那也许我也去报名一个。
Yeah. But the last time I played outside, I played with this guy. We smoked pot together. You know, he was adorable, whatever. Thank you. And then we were all playing. And then at the end of the game, we finished
对。但上次我在户外打球时，我和这个家伙一起打。我们一起抽了点大麻。你知道的，他很可爱，管他呢。谢谢。然后我们都在打球。接着在比赛结束时，我们打完了，
and that guy had left a little early. He had taken like five different people's car keys. No way. And then press them to see what went boop, boop. And then got in one and stole one of the guy's cars. Wow. This is the cute stoner. He's all, he's all stoned up.
那家伙稍微提前走了。他拿了大概五个不同的人的车钥匙。不会吧。然后按按看哪把钥匙能让车“哔哔”响。接着上了一辆车，把其中一个人的车给偷走了。哇。这就是那个可爱的“大麻客”。他全身上下都“麻”了。
He's all weeded up. Yeah. Well, I liked to smoke pot when I play basketball because I become incredible or terrible, but it's a grab bag. I'm willing to. Oh, hang on, hang on. We'd love to get you to repeat that for a PSA
他浑身都是大麻味。对。好吧，我喜欢在打篮球时抽大麻，因为我会变得不可思议或者糟糕透顶，但这全凭运气。我愿意。哦，等等，等等。如果你能为公益广告重新录制这段话，我们会非常感激的，
if we could real quick. Just. Hi, I'm Sarah Silverman. You know, when I play basketball, I feel marijuana enhances my game or puts me into a ball, but either way, it's worth the risk. But you also like to smoke it
如果可以的话，就快点。就说。嗨，我叫萨拉·西尔弗曼。你知道，当我打篮球时，我觉得大麻能提升我的水平，或者让我进入状态，但不管怎样，这都是值得冒的险。不过你也喜欢在
when you're not playing basketball. I like to have a puff at night. And that's nice. A little night, night puff, puff. Now, do you follow professional basketball? Are you a Laker fan? You know, I like watching it. I mostly like watching like a close game
不打篮球的时候抽它。我喜欢在晚上抽一口。那挺好的。来上一口舒适的晚安烟。现在，你关注职业篮球吗？你是湖人队的球迷吗？你知道的，我喜欢看。我最喜欢看那种最后半场、最后一节比分焦灼的比赛。我没有，我没有什么痴迷的球队之类的事。
in the last half, last quarter. I'm not, I don't have like a team that I'm obsessed with or something. It's tough to watch the first three quarters. I like any underdogs. I mean, but then again, I also like the Warriors just cause I love Steve Kerr and, you know, and I like the Lakers and I like the Celtics,
前三节很难看下去。我喜欢任何处于劣势的队伍。我是说，话虽如此，我也喜欢勇士队，因为我喜欢史蒂夫·科尔（Steve Kerr），而且，我也喜欢湖人队和凯尔特人队，但纯粹是出于各种不同的原因。所以萨拉，你的履历太疯狂了，因为你不仅是个优秀的单口喜剧演员，而且你还参与了一些非常棒、令人难忘的节目，你知道的，周六夜现场（SNL）这种标志性节目，我是说，SNL，大秀（Mr. Show），拉里·桑德斯（The Larry Sanders Show）。我的天，你能参与所有这些对像我这样的人来说——
but only just cause of various reasons. So Sarah, your resume is so crazy because not only are you an incredible standup, but you've been part of some just great memorable shows, you know, SNL iconic shows, I should say, SNL, Mr. Show, Larry Sanders. I mean, it's incredible that you got to be part of all these things that for somebody like me
你快要哭了吗？我在努力。坚持住。给我点时间。我他妈在努力哭呢。天哪，你把气氛破坏了。不，我再也酝酿不出来了。
were shows that really, that really kind of spoke to- Are you gonna cry? I'm trying to. Keep it together. Just give me a second. I'm trying to fucking cry. Jesus, you just broke it. No, I'll never get there.
不，我再也酝酿不出来了。但是，但是这些节目，你知道的，像《大秀》和《拉里·桑德斯秀》，它们向我展示了，我当时就想，哦，等等，我也想搞那种破玩意儿。对，它们就像是喜剧界的黄金节目。天哪。对，就像是，设定了标准。我是说，我能参与所有这些标志性节目，
No, I'll never get there. But, but these are shows that like, you know, Mr. Show and Larry Sanders were, they showed me, I was like, oh wait, I want to do that kind of shit. Yeah, they're like comedy gold shows. Oh my God. Yeah, like, yeah, set the standard. I mean, I got to be on all of those are iconic shows
而我什么都没，你知道的，我就像是电影《西力传》（Zellig）里的人物。我只是非常幸运，最后误打误撞进了一——才不是呢。我可不是在谦虚。我只是，你知道的，我跟创造这些东西毫无关系，我是说，但确实是的。我曾参演过很多那种狂热粉丝众多的《星际迷航：航海家号》（Star Trek Voyager）。
that I had nothing, you know, I was like, Zellig. I just got very lucky and ended up in- Not true. I'm not being modest. I just, you know, I had nothing to do with creating the, you know, I mean, but yeah, it is. It's, I've been in a lot of like very culty Star Trek Voyager.
我知道，我爱死那个了。等等，你在SNL的经历是怎样的？你现在还看吗？对，我看。我看。我是它的粉丝。你会把刚才的停顿在后期剪掉吗？不，不，不，不，我是说，我在那儿的那一年，
I know, I love that. Wait, what was your time like at SNL? And, and do you watch it now? Yeah, I watch it. I watch it. And I'm a fan of it. Would you take the pause out in post? No, no, no, no, I mean, I had the year that was there.
我永远都不想收回。那段经历很艰难、漫长、令人沮丧，你知道的，但我跟所有人都处得很好，你知道的，诸如此类。那确实是一个不同的时代。你知道的，我是说，那会儿他们还没有电脑。我们是在法律垫纸（legal pads）上写小品，然后交给一屋子的打字员。
I would never want to take back. It was like hard and it was long and it was frustrating and, you know, but I got along with everybody, you know, and stuff. It was really a different time. You know, I mean, it was, I mean, they didn't have computers. Like we wrote our sketches on legal pads and gave it to a room of typists.
真的。哇。好吧，你喜欢在纽约的生活吗？我爱纽约。是的。我18岁时搬到那里。我爱纽约。我喜欢漫步街头。你希望你，你还住在那里吗？好吧，为什么你，因为我很想住在那里，
Right. Wow. Well, how did you like living in New York? I love New York. Yeah. I moved there when I was 18. I love New York. I love just walking through the streets. Do you wish you, you still live there? Well, why do you, cause I'd love to live there,
但我出于其他原因必须住在L.A.。我也很想住在那里，但，我是说，我最后一次在那儿租公寓时，房租是450美元。你知道的，我住在个五层步梯房里，你知道的，我们，我们楼里住着个男的。我们有自己的洗手间，但那栋楼的走廊里有很多挂着锁的洗手间是各个公寓共用的。
but I have to live here for other reasons. I'd love to live there too, but I, I mean, the last time I had an apartment there, it was $450. You know, I lived on a five floor walkup where I, you know, we, there was a guy who lived on our floor. We had our own bathroom, but it was a building that had a lot of like padlocked bathrooms in the hallway that the apartments shared.
那是个挺阴暗的地方。然后有个刚出狱的家伙就住在我们那一层，我和我的室友正走下楼，他和一个朋友走在我们后面，结果他掉了一盒子子弹。子弹就这样从我们的腿边滚落，从我们的腿缝间一直滚下楼梯，而我们俩谁都没有理会。
It was a real dark kind of place. And then this guy who just got out of prison lived in on our floor and my roommate and I were walking downstairs and he was walking behind us with a friend and he dropped a box of bullets. Bullets were just running down our legs, running through our legs down the stairs and neither of us acknowledged it.
那是一个非常阴暗的地方。然后有个刚出狱的家伙住在我们那一层，我和室友正走下楼梯，他和一个朋友走在我们后面，他掉了一盒子子弹。子弹直接滚到我们的脚边，顺着楼梯滚了下去，而我们两个谁都没有理会。
We just acted like it was not happening. We were so scared. That's hilarious. Sarah, who do you find absolutely hilarious? Like either growing up or now, like who you're just like, oh my God, I can't get enough of blank cause they're so funny. So many people I know if I stared off.
我们只是装作什么都没发生。我们当时吓坏了。太搞笑了。莎拉，你觉得谁绝对是个搞笑天才？无论是小时候还是现在，你觉得谁让你——天哪，我怎么也看不够这个人的节目，因为他们太逗了？我认识的很多人，如果我一开始……
Have you seen Kate Berlant? She's incredible. I love Tig Notaro. I love Zach Galfinakis. I love Kyle Dunnigan, this guy Kyle Dunnigan, he just, you know, they're people that just make you, you know, or like- Zach acts like that for me.
你看过凯特·贝兰特（Kate Berlant）的表演吗？她太棒了。我喜欢蒂格·诺塔罗（Tig Notaro）。我喜欢扎克·加利费安纳基斯（Zach Galifianakis）。我喜欢凯尔·邓尼根（Kyle Dunnigan），这个叫凯尔·邓尼根的家伙，他就是，你知道的，总有些人能让你，你知道的，或者像——扎克对我的影响就是这样。
Zach kills me, kills me. So funny. And then he's just got this huge heart too and you know, he's just like a good, such a solid, lovely person and he's so funny, you know. I like- What about back in the day, somebody who made you laugh that, well, I guess you can't really say
扎克简直笑死我了，笑死我了。太搞笑了。而且他内心也超级善良，你知道的，他就是那种很好、很踏实、很可爱的、又那么幽默的人，你懂的。我喜欢——那以前呢，有什么人让你觉得很好笑，不过，我想你其实不能说
who made you laugh back then, but based on how your sense of humor has changed now, kind of doesn't. I mean, there's certainly television shows and movies that I thought were funny back then that I would watch today and go, oh no, that doesn't hold up. Or my sense of humor has just changed.
当年是谁逗笑了你，但鉴别一下你现在的幽默感是怎么变的，其实也无所谓。我的意思是，过去肯定有一些电视节目和电影，我当时觉得挺搞笑，但要是放到今天来看，我会觉得，哦不，这经不起推敲了。或者说我的幽默感已经变了。
Yeah, I mean, I've gone so many directions, like my friend Mark Cohen years ago, when I first started, he'd put a nickel on his head and say Jewish Ash Wednesday and I cried cause I was so sensitive. And then I went like 180 degrees, you know, but I'm the same inside, you know, but like I was so upset by that, you know. Oh really?
对啊，我的意思是，我的思路经历了好多个方向，比如我的朋友马克·科恩（Mark Cohen）多年前，我刚出道的时候，他会在头上放一枚硬币，然后说这是“犹太圣灰星期三”，我都快哭了，因为我当时太敏感了。然后我的风格就来了个180度大转弯，你知道的，但我内心还是那个我，你知道的，不过我当时真的被气坏了，你知道的。哦真的吗？
Yeah, an example of how people change, people's tastes change and you kind of have to, you find yourself trying not to factor that in when you're thinking of stuff that might be best suited for something that needs to appeal to a wide audience because the people who are financing this don't want it to appeal to a narrow audience. Do you have to fight that urge?
对，这就是个例子，说明人们是怎么改变的，人们的品味会变，而你往往会发现，当你在构思一些最适合大众口味的内容时，你得努力不去考虑这些因素，因为给这些项目出资的人可不想让它只迎合一小撮人。你必须得跟这种冲动做斗争吗？
That's why I think I prefer to be niche. Right. You know what I mean? Like, there's a lot of rules in the mainstream. Right. That's why I'm doing this podcast now. And called the Sarah Silverman podcast. And the one cool thing about it is like,
这就是为什么我觉得我更喜欢搞小众。对。你明白我的意思吗？主流里有太多的清规戒律。对。这就是为什么我现在要搞这个播客。名叫《莎拉·西尔弗曼播客》。它有一个很酷的地方在于，
even if you're on cable or streaming or something, I mean, you can really say anything. I think I said, fuck way too many times in the first few episodes because I felt so free and you have to have the kind of, get those same lessons that you have when you do stand up where it's like, now it's just gratuitous, it's lost any power,
哪怕你是在有线电视、流媒体还是别的什么平台，我的意思是，你真的什么都能说。我觉得我在前几集里“他妈的”这个词用得有点太多了，因为我当时感觉太自由了，你必须要吸取教训，就像你做单口喜剧时学到的一样，那就是：现在这纯粹是废话连篇，已经没有任何力量了，
it isn't cool, you're using it as a crutch, but I had to kind of learn it over again because I was suddenly so excited to get to say anything I wanted that I was like, fucking this and fucking that and I listened back and I was just like, yay, yay, yay. What I always thought you did such a great job of doing, you do it when you were like on a panel,
一点也不酷，你只是把它当成了敷衍的拐杖，但我必须重新去适应，因为我当时突然太兴奋了，终于可以畅所欲言，我想说啥就说啥，我就开始“他妈的这个，他妈的那个”，等我回头一听，我就觉得：呃，呃，呃。我一直觉得你特别擅长的一点——你上圆桌访谈节目时就会这样，
like on a, your guest on a talk show or whatever, you found ways to, I think a lot of people, you were for a long time considered kind of like dirty or you would do, you would dress jokes up, you never knew what you'd trojan horse, like you'd come in and you'd dress it up and be kind of super bright about it. And then the punchline would be really dark.
比如去一档脱口秀节目当嘉宾之类的，你总能找到方法——我觉得很多人，你在很长一段时间里被认为有点“低俗”，或者你会把笑话包装一下，你永远不知道你会用什么“特洛伊木马”战术，比如你登台时把它好好包装一番，表现得超级阳光。然后包袱（笑点）却非常暗黑。
And you found a way to constantly, it's kind of going back to Sean, I feel I sound like an old man, like you're edgy, but you found ways to push the boundary and you didn't necessarily swear, but you did not shy away from making jokes that were hit really hard. I never felt dirty, like everyone would be like,
你总能找到方法不断地——这有点像回到肖恩的话题，我觉得自己听起来像个老头子——你很有棱角（前卫），但你总能找到方法去突破界限，而且你未必会说脏话，但你也绝不回避那些重磅出击的笑料。我从来不觉得自己低俗，尽管每个人都会说：
she's a putty mouth and she's dirty. And I guess I am, but like I never feel that way because I was raised in a house where you used just the words weren't taboo, you know? So it's not like I swear a lot really, it's not like I use technical language or explicit maybe. Yeah, right, you didn't say fuck a lot, you didn't do that at all.
她满嘴脏话，她很低俗。我想我确实是吧，但我从来不觉得自己是那样，因为我是在这样一个家庭里长大的：你用那些词，它们本来就不是什么禁忌，你知道的？所以我其实并不是经常说脏话，我也不是在用什么专业术语或者特别露骨的语言。对啊，没错，你并不经常说“操”，你根本不说那类词。
Like you found a way to bring people to a punchline that was potentially really, they hadn't heard it before and it was kind of dangerous and you were kind of pushing the boundaries. Can I ask you this? So are there any kind of, Jason asked you if you wanna do like a drama or anything like that, but are there any like comedy people for reals
就像你总能找到方法把大家引入一个包袱，这个包袱可能潜力无限，是他们以前没听过的，而且有点危险，你在不断试探底线。我能问你个问题吗？那么，有没有哪种——杰森问过你想不想演正剧或者类似的东西，但有没有哪种真正的喜剧界人士
that you would wanna work with or comedy directors that you think like, oh, I can. You know, I haven't done a lot of comedy. Well, this is the thing is the things I've been in, in comedy, like in movies, it's like this has changed a lot, but since, you know, it's the angry girlfriend or the angry roommate or the sleazebag executive.
是你特别想合作的，或者你觉得“哦，我可以”的喜剧导演？你知道的，我没拍过多少喜剧。好吧，问题是，我拍过的那些喜剧，比如电影里——虽然现在情况已经变了很多，但自从，你知道的，不是演生气的女友，就是生气的室友，或者卑鄙的行政高管。
But it's like, so I go, after a while I go, I just don't even wanna be in comedies because the access I have to comedies is, I can't be a comedian in a comedy playing a straight role. It doesn't, it's stupid of me. It doesn't, I don't make money from doing movies. I lose money making movies. I get the least amount of money.
但问题是，过了一段时间我就想了，我甚至都不想演喜剧了，因为我接触喜剧的途径是——我不能在一个喜剧里扮演一个正经角色却不发挥喜剧演员的作用。这太蠢了。拍电影对我来说赚不到钱。拍电影让我赔钱。我拿到的片酬是最少的。
I can't be on the road. You know, so that's why it's like dramas or something where I'm in like someone else's domain is it just makes sense. I just wanna play, if I'm in a comedy, I wanna be funny in it. And otherwise, you know, I just wanna do interesting things that, you know,
我也不能去全国巡演。你知道的，所以这就是为什么正剧或者其他什么需要我去别人领域里发挥的角色，才真正说得通。我只是想演戏，如果我演喜剧，我就想在里面负责搞笑。除此以外，你知道的，我只想做一些有意思的事，
I like acting, but I like doing everything. Sarah, I don't even know where to go. I mean, we could talk to you all day. It's so fun having you here. You've been talking for so long. I can't imagine, I'm so sorry. We're taking a lot of your time. Very generous.
我喜欢表演，但我什么都想尝试。莎拉，我都不知道该接什么话了。我的意思是，我们可以跟你聊上一整天。你能来这里真的太有意思了。你已经聊了这么久了。我都无法想象，实在不好意思。我们占用了你太多时间。你太慷慨了。
I'm so happy to be just seeing you and talking to you. Likewise. But we'll wrap it up. Let's, someone wrap it up. We're gonna wrap it up, but we're gonna say, you're an absolute delight. You are a, you're a comic titan. I'm gonna say that.
我能见到你并跟你聊天，我真的太高兴了。彼此彼此。不过我们要收尾了。来吧，谁来做个收尾。我们要收尾了，但我们要说，你绝对是个极品开心果。你是一个，你是喜剧界的泰斗。我要这么说。
I find you to be so fucking consistently hilarious. You've made me laugh so many millions of times. So thank you. Royalty. Yeah. Royalty. Doesn't it make you feel all day? I remember when Joan, when you'd go,
我觉得你他妈的总是这么搞笑。你让我笑了成百万次。所以谢谢你。皇室。对。皇室。这难道不让你觉得……我记得当琼（Joan Rivers）——每当你说，
oh, Joan, you're a legend. She'd be like, fuck you. I'm still vital. You know, like it makes you feel done. Yeah. The next thing I do, you know how like your agent will go, ooh, but we got with or and for the credits. And you go, huh?
哦，琼，你是个传奇。她就会说：去你妈的。老娘还很有活力呢。你知道的，这会让你觉得自己像个废人。对。我接下来的作品，你知道你的经纪人会怎么说吗，“哦，不过我们在演员表里争取到了‘与……联合主演’或者‘为……主演’的署名权。”然后你会说：“啊？”
Yeah. Who cares? I use that a thing. I want and introducing. That's really. Sure. I want them to fight for that. My thing I keep going to is I'm asking my,
对。谁在乎啊？我以前把这当回事。我想要“特别介绍”。真的。我希望他们为这个争破头。我一直挂在嘴边的一招是，我在问我的，
I'm like, I want to fight for in advance, fight for my position in the, in memoriam segment on like the Emmys and stuff. Oh, I'm already working on my real. I want to get the final, yeah. Final card. Yeah. Fuck, and I want to bring down the fucking.
我说，我想争取提前锁定，争取在艾美奖之类的“缅怀逝者”环节里占据一个显眼的位置。哦，我已经开始筹备我的回顾短片了。我想获得压轴的，对。最后一张卡片。对。他妈的，我还想把整个——
Do you know the song, Will? Do you know the song you want to play? $5 footloat. $5 footloat, I love that fucking song. We love you, Sarah. Thank you, Sarah. Bye, Sarah. Thank you.
你知道那首歌吗，威尔？你知道你想放哪首歌吗？5美元长脚面包。5美元长脚面包，我太喜欢这他妈的歌了。我们爱你，莎拉。谢谢你，莎拉。再见，莎拉。谢谢。
Bye, Sarah Silverman. Bye, thanks so much. So funny, always, you know, there's that gross word again, but always edgy, dark. Like she's the kind of comedy you choose when you really want to, it's like truth comedy. You know?
再见，莎拉·西尔弗曼。再见，非常感谢。总是那么搞笑，你知道的，又出现那个粗俗的词了，但总是那么前卫、暗黑。就像她是那种当你真正想要的时候会选择的喜剧风格，这就像是真实派喜剧。你知道吗？
Yeah, I always thought of it. And she's one of the cool kids. Like she was just so funny in such a great real, like where you're like, shit, man, I just don't want to fuck up around her. Yeah. She's so funny. You know, that's how I always-
对，我一直这么认为。而且她是个酷女孩。就像她搞笑得那么自然真实，以至于你会想：操，老娘在她身边可千万别搞砸了。对。她太搞笑了。你知道，我一直都是——
I don't want to be unfunny at any moment. Yeah, I don't want to be a fucking loser. Shit, you're so stupid to even think that. And then I just don't even get out of my car. I'd love to go see her. Do you stand up? I don't think I've ever- I saw her do a stand up at the Improv and Melrose
我不想在任何时刻表现得不好笑。对，我可不想当个失败的混蛋。操，竟然会有这种想法，你也太蠢了。然后我甚至连车都不想下了。我很想去看她的现场。你看过单口喜剧吗？我想我从来没——我在梅尔罗斯大道（Melrose）的即兴喜剧俱乐部（Improv）看过她的单口喜剧演出，
and her opening joke was about rape. Yeah. This is sort of, drop the flag and say, here it comes. Yeah. So you have to be a fan and be open-minded, but I am and I'm a huge, huge fan. Well, I think, you know, and she made such a great point. You, she's made a lot of jokes
她的开场笑话就是关于强奸的。对。这有点像，直接竖起旗帜说：高能预警来了。对。所以你得是个粉丝，思想还得开放，但我确实是，而且我是她超级、超级大的粉丝。嗯，我觉得，你知道的，她说的太对了。你，她讲过很多笑话，
that like has taken people back over the years or whatever, but she's right. It's all about intention and her intention is good. She's a good person and she's going the right direction. And she wants, I think that sometimes she has to make jokes like that to kind of shed light on the other side. And that's her style. Yeah.
这些笑话多年来让人们大吃一惊或者别的什么，但她是正确的。这一切都关乎意图，而她的意图是好的。她是个好人，她走在正确的道路上。她希望——我觉得有时她必须开那种玩笑，才能去照亮阴暗的另一面。这就是她的风格。对。
And I love it. I respect it. And she's got a new podcast, the Sarah Silverman podcast, and it is great, of course. I've heard it. It's fantastic. Yeah. It's super good.
我爱极了。我尊重它。她有一个新播客，叫《莎拉·西尔弗曼播客》，当然，它棒极了。我听过了。太棒了。对。超级好看。
And she's a Stone Cold babe. Yeah, she's Stone Cold babe. She's babe. She's a Stone Cold babe. And you know what the third thing is? Yeah, we can say that. The third thing is, um... Bye.
而且她是个绝色大美女。对，她是个绝色大美女。她是美女。她是个绝色大美女。你知道第三点是什么吗？对，我们可以这么说。第三点是……再见。
Bye. Bye. Bye. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
再见。再见。再见。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. That's it. Thethat again?
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。就这样。刚才那个是？
Oh, thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
哦，谢谢。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。